[Music]
we look at the word differently and also
we look we are half of the population
and we deserve to be listening for me
the most important thing is to ensure
that all people are are included when we
talk about equality and in this moment
we often forget that they're different
people and especially women who are
marginalized because they're women and
because they're trans or Muslim or
migrant or Roma it's about bringing a
new dimension into politics you know
some topics are just too important to be
only let's decided by a man so I believe
women should have a right and a voice to
speak for themselves for a very long
time I have been discriminated because
of who I Who I am you can always go
further I think and still like this they
have no female a prime minister for
instance in my opinion one of the
biggest problems is still unfortunately
women poverty especially when it comes
to older women disabled women women
coming from minorities or different
backgrounds also migrant women what that
means what normal behavior means it
means more people bullied at school
because of who they are it means more
people discriminated at work because of
who they are it means not being able to
have your gender expression or gender
identity or sexual orientation because
of who you are and it should change and
I think it's time to that women step up
and be in control
[Music]